before I even ask my questions can we go
back to AAA what was the other thing you
wanted to mention the idea uh making a
more direct connection between a family
relationship between Irene and uh and
Lorraine and um which uh I'm not saying
there is I'm just saying that's up for
interpretation as you see the movie and
you start to kind of like you know put
the pieces together but I thought that
was a really compelling idea and um
and it's funny because there was things
in it that I actually thought were very
explicit in the movie that were cut in
that um you know it's press day I've
been talking to lots of people so most
people do not get have not picked that
up but there was a couple things that
are very explicit
about that would potentially reveal that
if you looked carefully at the movie but
I think I think probably sometimes it
just goes too fast or they don't don't
catch the little details or you're just
so terrified you can't pay attention to
the details your movie's too scary
that's why people didn't pick up on
it I have a I have a question about I
guess this is kind of about the first
nun and then also The Conjuring so at
the end of the first nun movie it
confirms that edin Lorraine performed an
exorcism on Frenchie so does that mean
at the end of your movie Valic still
hasn't left Frenchie um you know that
would be up to
interpretation the uh you know was uh
yeah there's a moment in the end of the
movie where I I think that well there's
a couple moments there's there's a mid
credit that uh would might might tease
something obviously in the timeline of
The Conjuring to like answer the it
directly we think he is uh he saved at
the end of this movie but we know that
later on before the events of the first
Conjuring but after this movie he is
possessed and that leads to it's a
failed uh it's a failed Exorcist that
leads to his him taking his life um so
we know that's coming now valac either
gets back into him or valac might still
be in there and I think that's really
open to interpretation um there's
definitely a moment in the
[Music]
um I think there's a there's a look
between the two of them that I think if
you know at the very end that I think it
says a lot I think that there's
definitely something there and you could
just see that um you know
Irene Irene has got a second sight she
knows that there's you know she sees
things that aren't always there and I
feel like watch your eyes like watch
your eyes in the
end now I have yet another reason to go
back and watch this again I want to make
sure I squeeze this question in because
it's one of my absolute favorite parts
of your movie it's your goat devil can
you kind of walk us through what it took
to create something like that
specifically in terms of how much of it
is practically done on set versus things
that are enhanced and post it's it's
almost all wait real actor all practical
with the exception of his feet and his
uh his yeah his feet basically for
safety issues we wanted to we had claws
they were it was dangerous for him to
especially because there's that scene
going down the stairs it was just
dangerous for him to work on those so we
needed to have something that that had
more grip so that was a CG extension but
he's all real Prosthetics are real all
we did is we moved his eyes like
slightly to the side just so it wasn't
like a guy in a a face Mas mask like it
just we moved his like digitally his
eyes over to the side but like the
Prosthetics there were like and that was
so fun it took forever to get him in and
out of that but um you know Dracula Bram
Stoker's Dracula was one of The
Inspirations of this I loved that bat
creature I don't know if you remember
the bat creature that comes out of the
closet like is my favorite moments that
or goes into the closet one of my
favorite moments in that movie and that
was one of the big references that I
gave to the team I was like this it
needs to kind of have this Vibe it like
because that totally freaked me out and
um as a kid so I was like that that's
the spirit the whole progression of how
you use that throughout the movie spoton
I absolutely loved it and I mean it the
nun two you crushed it job well done
huge congratulations thank you per that
means a
lot and